UN Special Rapporteur on extrajudicial
summary or arbitrary executions has just
ended a two-week visit to Nigeria
Agnes calamar has been looking at
alleged abuses committed by security
forces in the north and south where a
separatist movement has been gaining
ground well calm art is warning the
Nigerian government to address what
she's calling a pressure cooker of
violence that is claiming thousands of
life a report also highlights excessive
use of force by police leading to
killings and lack of investigations and
prosecutions for those committing human
rights abuses with calamari says she
found an absence of accountability and a
lack of justice for victims
well Agnes Kalmar joins us live now from
Abuja and Agnes thank you very much for
joining us on the program that is a
pretty long list there tell us more
about what your a visit to Nigeria has
uncovered I noticed the phrase in your
press conference either the earlier a
pressure cooker of violence so what did
you find well I could not really use any
other words than pressure cooker I have
found localized and countrywide patterns
of violence that are simmering and my my
main concerns with those localized and
countrywide systems of violence is that
they are now taking place in a context
characterized by population explosion by
an increased number of people living in
extreme poverty by the proliferation of
weapons coming from throughout the
region of West Africa and by the
environmental degradation
so those external pressure applied on
top of those ecosystems eco political
systems of violence are ready to
conflate to explode
in a way which I don't think we have yet
completely understood so my my
preliminary finding today was really to
issue this this warning bus to the
government and to the international
community there is in Nigeria pressure
cooker that if it is unchecked could
have ripple effect throughout the
regions and now is the time to
prioritize the rule of law and
accountability for the people of Nigeria
Agnes you use the word crisis and said
in your press conference that you know
you don't want the government to pretend
this is not a crisis but how do they
view the situation that you bring up in
your report when you will have to ask
them I think I don't think I have made
any sharp or stark revelations to the
government whether or not authorities
are willing to admit the extent of the
problem is a different matter but in all
my meetings with officials in the
majority of my meetings with official
there is an acknowledgement of the scale
and the extent of the problems that
gives me some hope that the authorities
with the necessary leadership and
political will will be able to begin a
roadmap towards addressing the lack of
accountability towards ensuring that
killings particularly by the police but
not only that all the killings are
investigated that the systemic factors
such as the lack of resources of the
police a lack of training that all those
resources all those resources issues are
addressed let me remind you that
Nigeria is a middle-income country so I
have approached the questions of
arbitrary killings
within that context and what I have
found is not in keeping with what I
would expect from a middle-level country
a middle-income country so Agnes
calamari is what you're saying that
there are resources that can be put to
work in solving some of these problems
but the right priorities are perhaps not
being made yes I believe that at the
moment the rule of law and
accountability have not been
sufficiently prioritized I can take for
proof the fact that in 2006 one of my
predecessors went on a mission and when
I compared what he has found with what I
have found there are so little
differences between the two report it is
shocking there are 15 years apart so now
is the time to prioritize the rule of
law and accountability there is a
securitisation strategy to address many
problems but security without
accountability is not a solution for the
long term I'm not even sure it's a
solution for the short term it's just a
containment policy a containment in 2019
when the country is confronting the
global processes I have identified of
population explosion increase poverty
environmental degradation that
containment policy is not gonna work is
not gonna work so it is time more than
time too much time has been wasted it is
time to prioritize the rule of law and
accountability for the people of Nigeria
particularly for the 49 millions that
are living in extreme poverty did you
find that there was any positive change
yes yes I have found a few positive
changes now for instance in the
Northeast you you were mentioning the
the conflict against Boko Haram in
2015-2016
that region was at the center of many
concerns for human rights violations by
Boko Haram of course but also by the
security agencies there was a vast
number of allegations of arbitrary
killing disproportionate indiscriminate
bombing disappearances kill death in
custody massive deaths in custody in
fact now those problems have not been
investigated and there is still not any
accountability for those past violations
but the progress residing the fact that
allegations over the last two years 2018
and 2019 have decreased so for instance
allegations of arbitrary depravation of
life they are far less of them than they
were three years ago that I take as a
positive sign now I would like this
positive sign to be to those positive
sign I would like to see steps taken to
ensure accountability for past crimes I
would particularly like the many
disappearances that have been brought to
my attention by the children the wives
the daughters and and and son of many
disappeared men I would like for those
disappearances to be addressed as a
matter of urgency because the torture it
is creating for the people left behind
cannot be under underestimated agonistic
Halima they're joining us UN Special
Rapporteur thank you very much for
joining us thank you